have a little bit of breaking news
concerning regulations over christmas
uh sam coats has that same confirmation
that
as we expected all morning it looks as
if the rules for christmas
are not going to change in any nation of
the united kingdom
uh a source close to the government uh
has said that the uk regions
uh have decided that they're not going
to change any of it political leaders
have however agreed to stronger
messaging around the need for people to
limit their contact
at christmas the public will be urged to
keep travel
to a minimum and use common sense in
regard to the
social contact uh contract now
this in many ways is a bit of a victory
for boris johnson who's prevailed on the
other leaders particularly sturgeon who
as we were saying a moment ago might
have wanted us like toughening of the
uh of the rules but in the end i think
that ministers came down on the side
that a promise was a promise and that
it's very hard to unpick when
plans have been made uh and uh
arrangements have been finalized and it
is christmas is just
the end of next week um but there is a
risk
scientists medics and quite possibly the
labour party on the other side of that
of that divide calling for